hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
sc.l2-3.13.9 terminate network
connections associated with
communication sessions at the end of the
sessions are after a defined period of
inactivity
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP 800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so what's the story here well
basically the idea is that we don't want
to leave the window open for the
boyfriend to come in late at night
simply put idle connections are a
massive problem because if the system is
compromised and you don't know it and if
that connection to the secure system
containing cui is on all they have to do
is wait a few hours to make sure you
went to bed and there's no activity and
boom they're in the window baby they're
already climbing in and because you left
the window open there's nothing to tell
you that they're there doing bad things
anyway the solvency for this making sure
and the solvency for this is making sure
that when you are done with a connection
you close it or there's an automated
method of closing it such as terminate
on idle time setup or your vpns and
remote applications idle time so let's
dive into specifics of how this one is
assessed three major assessment points
on this one determine if a period of
inactivity to terminate network
connections associated with
communication sessions is defined so did
we Define a period of inactivity so
again the control specifically calls out
an activity as a method for terminating
network connections so there's not
really a lot of guesswork on that that's
kind of nice so what are we going to say
we're going to say hey yes it's
implemented via the VPN policy to
determinate connections after X number
of minutes maybe it's five maybe it's 30
whatever it may be of idle activity
defined in the firewall or whatever it
is that's mandating your uh or managing
your VPN
assessment Point number two determine if
network connections associated with
communication sessions are terminated at
the end of the sessions uh again we
might give an example of uh you know VPN
policy to terminate connections after 30
minutes of idle activity defined in the
firewall it operations policy states
connection should be terminated when
work is complete so a couple different
areas we may look there
final assessment Point determine if
network connections Associated
communication sessions are terminated
after the defined period of an activity
this is implemented via VPN policy to
terminate connections after 30 minutes
of idle activity and that may be defined
a firewall maybe it's defined somewhere
in group policy whatever it may be
depends on how your VPN is set up
now at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who've had
this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day
[Music]
Chris Blatt we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps gray
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon slam more Defense
work with higher profit margins that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and that's what being
amazing kind of looks like
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the Bible below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out until the next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]